hey guys we're the cast of stranger  things and we're here at Madame Tussauds  Wax Museum in Times Square  things got strange as the cast of  stranger things joined Jimmy Fallon to  scare unsuspecting fans at the famed Wax  Museum in New York City nothing about  this is okay here's the setup the cast  stood frozen posing as wax figures in a  stranger things themed room  [Applause]  fans entered the room thinking they were  going to pose for a photo with the wax  figures but surprise we wanted to do  something crazy and creative and I feel  like you know we accomplished that the  Adrenaline's pumping right yes one of  the scariest parts might have been Jimmy  Fallon's barb get up barb it has been  really wild to see it one fan even  trolled Fallon over the look however  Fallon did find one barb stand in the  audience  [Music]  you